le gouvernement hausse le ton contre les
hooligans on pensait le phénomène
maîtrisée depuis quelques années
plusieurs affaires récentes ont montré
qu'il n'en était rien un projet de loi
sera présenté dans les prochaines
semaines nous avons pu récupérer des
images tournées par un supporters il ya
un mois et elles sont édifiantes
il ne s'agit pas vous allez le voir de
bagarres isolées mais d'une violence
organisée délibéré enquête romain mais
si andré germain c'est une image rare
filmé par un amateur derrière le stade
du mans il ya un mois une bataille
rangée entre supporters d'un même club
le paris saint-germain
d'un côté les tigris de la tribune
auteuil du parc des princes au profil
black blanc beur de l'autre les boulogne
boys et leur frange raciste qui les
agressent auteuil face à boulogne 2
tribunes de supporters parisiens au parc
des princes un terrain les séparent mais
à l'extérieur les supporters sont réunis
dans un même bloc les bagarres se répète
depuis plus d'un mois avant
l'intervention tardive et crs pourquoi
ces affrontements d'abord une rivalité
chaque groupe de supporters se prétend
être le seul légitime mais surtout une
raison politique et sociale que la
mairie de parité non guillory tes
supporters dans la tribune boulogne
d'extrême droite proche de l'extrême
droite dure qui fait de cette tribune
boulogne est un champ je dirais
d'investigation pour ses objectifs
politiques avec l'expression un
caractère raciste le racisme qui
gangrène le parc des princes depuis des
années comme le montrent les saluts
nazis ou les croix celtique
repéré par les caméras de surveillance
la direction du club s'estime
impuissante et garde le silence les
joueurs eux se garde bien de prendre
parti entre les deux clans toujours
gênantes des supporters de
même équipe sait gérer sa fronde mais
mon cassoulet car c'est comme ça et
danois on va se préoccuper surtout du
terrain avant de lancer un projet de loi
prévoit d'interdire les supporters
racistes et violents d'entrer dans les
stades
il faudra bien ça si les supporters du
parc des princes veulent se supporter à
nouveau